[Musique]
nous trouvons sur le stade
geoffroy-guichard à saint-etienne auprès
de nous un des hommes les plus comblés
du football français robert herbin il à
être joué pendant 15 ans sous le maillot
vert de saint-etienne il a gagné le
championnat de france la coupe de france
le doublé coupe championnat il a été 24
fois international est depuis 72
il a mené deux fois les verts en demi
finale de la coupe d'europe des
champions
et puis robert herbin en collaboration
avec jean philippe reyt hacker a publié
un livre aux éditions robert laffont
football alors pour bellarmin merci de
nous avoir reçu d'abord on va jouer au
jeu des questions dix minutes pour
répondre avec rob érable plombier
première question
au contraire de professionnels du
football vous n'avez pas publier un
récit de souvenirs et d'anecdotes mais
une somme de conseils pratiques et
théoriques sur la tactique la technique
et l'entraînement alors avez vous
quelque chose de nouveau apporté non je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait quelque chose
de nouveau le football a toujours été ce
qu'il est avec une évolution bien sûr
dans l'organisation mais nous avons tenu
à faire ce bouquin avec jean-philippe
prêta caire parce qu'il n'existait pas
en france de livres purement technique
où il est expliqué la façon de toucher
le ballon avec les surfaces de contact
de la façon de frapper la balle la façon
de jouer sur un terrain avec
l'organisation tactique qui a évolué
depuis des dizaines d'années je crois
que c'est un bouquin qui s'imposait
parce que jusqu'à présent on a vu des
livres retraçant un petit peu la
carrière des joueurs avec certaines
anecdotes et puis ça s'arrêtait là or je
crois que ce bouquin finalement
s'adresse un petit peu à tous ceux qui
s'intéressent au football dans son
aspect technique
en ce qui concerne l'entraînement aussi
hélas sur l'entraînement nous disons
qu'avec jean philippe reyt acquiert nous
nous sommes appuyés sur ce que
sur ce qu est l entraînement à
saint-etienne parce que je crois que
saint-etienne a obtenu des résultats
assez satisfaisants et ce qui prouve que
l'entraînement que nous avons l'habitude
de faire quotidiennement est un
entraînement satisfaisant et qui peut
être pratiqué par tous les clubs
deuxième question
vous êtes particulièrement exigeants
envers les joueurs vous leur imposez un
entraînement intensif
d'aucuns ont même employer le mot
tortionnaires alors est-ce là le secret
de la et saint-etienne votre secret en
certains employés le moteur twinair je
crois que c'est exagéré non je crois que
ce qui se fait à saint-etienne d'abord
c'est un travail sérieux et constant
bien sûr la dose de travail augmenter
parce que je crois qu'il y a 10 ans 15
ans ou 20 ans le joueur professionnel
finalement n'était pas un véritable
professionnel le centre ne me sens trop
n'est pas assez sérieusement
par contre la dose de travail a été
peut-être un peu plus importante
les joueurs reviennent s'entraîner
l'après midi trois fois par semaine ce
qui fait des journées pratiquement
complète mais en ce qui concerne la
dureté du travail je ne pense pas que ce
soit dur les joueurs sont conscients
d'avoir à faire un travail physique
assez intensif et je pense que au long
de la saison selon les circonstances en
fonction de l'état physique de l'état
d'âme de mes joueurs et bien
l'entraînement varie est parfois
difficile parfois est plus décontractée
plus relâchée de toute façon ce qu'il
faut c'est du sérieux et de
l'obstination enfin de la continuité
dans le travail je crois que c'est un
petit peu ce qui a permis à
saint-etienne d'obtenir des résultats
jusqu'à présent
troisième question
le football est pratiqué par des jeunes
qui débutent vers 18 ans et qui sont
entraînés par des hommes beaucoup plus
âgés et des hommes qui sont investis de
responsabilité très importante
ses entraîneurs comprennent peut-il
encore les jeunes joueurs et ne
risque-t-il pas de les briser
c'est une question que l'on peut se
poser enfin personnellement je ne me la
suis pas posée parce que je crois que de
l'effectif que j'ai actuellement sous
mes ordres et bien il y as je crois deux
ou trois joueurs qui n'ont pas joué avec
moi le reste des joueurs sont des jeunes
qui ont fait leurs premières armes avec
moi j'étais leur capitaine à ce moment
là j'étais encore sur le terrain donc je
suis très proche d'eux je comprends je
crois à leur problème je sais ce qu'ils
doivent donner sur un terrain et en ce
domaine je ne crois pas qu'il puisse y
avoir de problème entre les conceptions
de l'entraîneur qui a 37 ans et des
joueurs qui ont 16 17 18 ans et un peu
plus quatrième question quelles qualités
fondamentales existe chez vous des
jeunes qui se présentent au centre de
formation de l'as saint-etienne eh bien
je crois d'abord
il faut que les jeunes soient très
sérieuse soit très passionnés de leur
métier soit prêt à faire beaucoup de
sacrifices pour exercer cette profession
et savoir que l'on a rien sans rien et
que c'est à force de travail que on
arrive à obtenir une place
dans l'élite des joueurs de football
c'est peut-être pas toujours le cas chez
certains joueurs mais je crois que à
saint-etienne à partir bien sûr de
qualité que l'on arrive à décerner à 16
17 ans des qualités naturellement
physique et natalité des qualités aussi
technique car il est indispensable
d'être bons footballeurs d'être bons
trucs de techniciens enfin ses qualités
je sais qu'elle ce travail par contre le
sérieux et puis la passion du métier ça
c'est quelque chose que l'on a ou que
l'on a pas et si on a pas et bien on a
de fortes chances de ne pas réussir dans
cette carrière ou alors échoué
rapidement mené une carrière de 4 5 ans
et puis ensuite ne plus savoir quoi
faire
est ce que les jeunes peuvent postuler
au centre de formation peut postuler je
ne le pense pas je crois que nous
faisons une sélection très très sérieuse
c'est monsieur garonnaire qui s'en
occupe par les relations qu'il a à
travers la france s'est finalement les
jeunes qui font qu'ils viennent à
saint-etienne pour se préparer à devenir
professionnels sont déjà des jeunes qui
ont de grosses qualités qui ont été
sélectionnés soit dans des équipes
cadets de région ou soit dans l'équipe
de france junior 5e question
dans le passé la majorité des joueurs
qui ont réussi dans la carrière du
football et est issu de la classe
sociale la plus défavorisée
alors pensez vous qu'il faille être
pauvre en avoir bavé pour accepter les
sacrifices du football c'est une
question bien sûr intéressante je crois
quand même que bien sûr
si l'on né d'une famille assez aisée où
on n'a pas peut-être à se poser de
problème quant à son avenir très proche
le joueur avait peut-être moins tendance
à fournir les efforts nécessaires
donc en général il est certain que les
jeunes qui réussissent dans le football
sont des jeunes qui au départ était de
famille assez pauvre et qui
naturellement souhaitait s'en sortir
puisque c'est une profession quand même
qui vous permet d'obtenir des situations
très favorables mais de plus en plus je
crois que j'ai affaire à des joueurs
maintenant peut-être pas de niveaux très
très élevée quant à la couche sociale
mais des garçons qui sont ils ont une
bonne éducation qui sont ouverts à tout
ça n'était pas le cas il ya 20 ans 6e
question
pourquoi tenter vous toujours de
préserver vos joueurs les plus jeunes en
particulier des caméras et des
journalistes
pour les plus jeunes en particulier je
crois que je fais ça avec pratiquement
tout mon effectif
c'est quelque chose je crois
indispensable parce que finalement les
caméras les journalistes les reporters
se déplace très souvent lors des grandes
confrontations saint-etienne depuis deux
ans réalise de belles performances en
coupe d'europe est naturellement
de trois jours avant le match de coupe
d'europe il y a énormément de monde qui
viennent assister à aux entraînements
qui est prêt à poser des interviews et
je crois que ça perturbe les joueurs
personnellement j'estime que les joueurs
ont besoin à ces périodes-là d'être très
concentré donc je demande à toutes les
personnes qui veulent faire des
interviews des reportages sur les
joueurs de faire ça de s'y prendre un
peu plus tôt devenir cinq six jours
avant le façon à ce que dans les trois
derniers jours et bien mes joueurs ne
soient plus perturbée par quoi que ce
soit et qu'ils le puissent se préparer
convenablement un quart de finale 1 8e
de finale où une demi finale de la coupe
d'europe c'est uniquement ça je crois
que il faut éviter à ses joueurs d'être
perturbée et puis aussi je crois que
je considère que le vedettariat ne
ressemble pas à grand chose
personnellement je suis contre cette
équipe de football c'est une équipe de
camarades de copains avec des qualités
différentes avec des joueurs de valeur
différente mais avant tout c'est un
groupe qui ne faut pas dissocier et les
reportages aurait tendance plutôt à
faire de tel ou tel joueur une vedette
ce qui ne serait peut-être pas très bon
pour l'équilibré de l'équipe 7e question
dans quelques heures les verts vont
pénétrer sur le terrain d'eindhoven pour
disputer un match dont l'issue tiendra à
très peu de choses alors quels conseils
ou quelles consignes lors donnerez-vous
quelques minutes avant le match fait des
gants singh elles sont assez strictes en
ce qui concerne le jeu défensif
je crois que les joueurs les connaissent
d'ailleurs elles peuvent être bien plus
marquée chez certains adversaires parce
que il y à des adversaires qui sont plus
valeureux est par contre en ce qui
concerne le jeu offensif et bien j'ai
toujours eu pour habitude de demander à
mes joueurs de jouer selon leur
inspiration
c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure je mets
lever un petit peu contre l'image de
l'entraîneur tyrannique je considère que
le football est un jeu d'inspiration
c'est un un jeu de création et les
joueurs dès qu'ils sont en possession du
ballon ce sont eux qui doivent imaginer
les actions qu'ils vont accomplir essayé
d'improviser enfin essayer de surprendre
l'adversaire par l'esprit d'initiative
qui est qu un petit peu caractéristique
aux français je crois que c'est quelque
chose indispensable donc chaque serait
peut-être mes conseils là-dessus tout en
sachant effet et
et en leur demandant de savoir sur le
plan physique s'est imposé car les
joueurs hollandais sont des gaillards
vraiment impressionnant sur le plan
athlétique pour vervins
merci de nous avoir reçu encore une fois
merci
[Musique]